Today, Africa is unfortunately known as the
poorest continent in the world by far.
From the trillion dollar bills found in Zimbabwe
to the 85% of Africans who live on less than
$5.50 per day, it’s no question the Africans
have had it tough.
However, there are a lucky few Africans, who
have been able to accumulate extraordinary
amounts of wealth.
One of these lucky Africans is Aliko Dangote
who is currently worth $11.9 billion.
So, here’s how Aliko Dangote became Africa’s
richest person.
Well, taking a look back, we have to go quite
a bit back in time as Aliko’s wealth literally
stretches back centuries starting with his
great grandfather, Alhassan Dantata.
Alhassan was born in 1877 in the Nigerian
town of Bebeji.
Though he had several siblings, life wasn’t
too bad as his parents were prosperous traders
and caravan leaders.
His father, Madugu Abdullahi, was also the
son of a successful merchant named Baba Talatin.
And Baba Talatin was also the son of a successful
merchant.
So, we have a long lineage of successful merchants,
but everything would turn upside down early
on in Alhassan’s life.
When Alhassan was 8 years old, his father
Abdullahi would pass away and his mother would
leave behind the children and move to Ghana.
As a result, Alhassan would find himself living
with an old slave woman named Tata.
Tata raised Alhassan and his siblings and
she basically became their mother.
In fact, Alhassan’s last name Dantata is
derived from the name of this woman.
In the Hausa language, Dantata means son of
Tata.
Though Tata was a loving woman and took care
of the children as if they were her own, as
you would guess, she didn’t have any money.
So, the kids had to earn their own money to
support themselves.
Some of them begged for food and clothes while
others chose to work for low wages.
Alhassan was one of the few that chose to
work, but just as he started to consistently
make enough money to support himself as a
teenager, the Kano civil war rolled around.
Alhassan and his siblings would be captured
and sold as slaves during the civil war.
Fortunately, the war didn’t last too long
and Alhassan would be able to purchase his
freedom after tensions settled down.
With basically no money left once again though,
Alhassan would travel to Ghana hoping that
his biological mother could help him.
To his disappointment though, his mother would
take Alhassan to a mallam, who is basically
a teacher, and she told him that he can stay
with the mallam until he was ready to return
to Bebeji.
Realizing that he was truly on his own, Alhassan
would do anything and everything possible
to earn a bit of money.
On Thursdays and Fridays, he worked for money
and during the rest of the days, he begged
for food.
Most of his earnings, though, went to his
mallam.
In an effort to break out of stagnation, Alhassan
would eventually move back to Bebeji and decide
to follow in the footsteps of his father.
Starting in 1906 at an age of 29, Alhassan
began trading various European goods including
beads, necklaces, and various cloths.
Alhassan conducted most of trades in the city
of Kano, but he decided to continue living
in Bebeji at first.
Eventually though, Alhassan would relocate
to Kano.
After 6 years of trading, Alhassan would finally
break out of poverty and move up to the middle
class.
In 1912, Europeans became interested in groundnuts,
and they contacted a bunch of well known merchants
in Kano to provide them with groundnuts.
At the time, Alhassan wasn’t nearly notable
enough to be contacted by the Europeans, but
he quickly realized the great opportunity
of exporting groundnuts.
You see, many merchants in Africa had become
extremely wealthy selling cocoa beans to the
Europeans, and Alhassan believed that he could
succeed in a similar manner using groundnuts.
But first he had to get noticed by a major
European exporter.
Now that Alhassan had his basic needs taken
care of, this was much easier.
Between 1912 and 1918, Alhassan would vigorously
build up his reputation in Kano and he would
save up every penny he made.
Apparently, he was extremely frugal.
He also worked on his English skills to make
it easier to trade with Europeans.
And just as he hoped, in 1918, the Royal Niger
Company owned by the British reached out to
Alhassan in hopes of trading groundnuts.
Alhassan would instantly accept the offer
and he would quickly get to work on establishing
his dominance in the trade.
Though Alhassan was unwilling to spend any
money on himself, he didn’t think twice
when it came to investing into his relationship
with the Niger Company.
While all of his fellow merchants used pack
animals to transport the goods, Alhassan used
the money he saved up over the past 12 years
to ship his groundnuts on steamships.
This earned him a lot of respect from the
Europeans and over the next few years, many
of them formed partnerships with Alhassan.
These European connections allowed Alhassan
to quickly scale up his other trading goods
as well including kola nuts, grains, precious
stones, and many more.
As his trading grew, Alhassan started to hire
employees, and some of them even lived with
him.
All of this European exposure allowed Alhassan
to quickly jump from being another successful
merchant to being the richest businessman
in Kano by 1922.
At this point, the hardest part of his journey
was behind him.
He had broken out of poverty, established
a name for himself, and now he was the richest
person in Kano.
All he had to do was maintain and grow his
business.
And this is exactly what Alhassan did for
the rest of his life.
In 1940, Alhassan would actually attempt to
open his exporting company.
This way, he didn’t have to rely on the
Royal Niger Company which was now known as
the United Africa Company.
However, his application to become an exporter
would be declined and Alhassan would be forced
to continue working as a middleman for European
companies.
This wasn’t a bad gig by any means though,
so Alhassan just focused on growing what he
had, and by the time he died in 1955, he would
grow to be the richest man in all of West
Africa.
It’s crazy to think that he started off
begging for food.
Anyway, moving forward, we have Alhassan’s
children and grandchildren.
Alhassan had raised his kids and grandchildren
with great appreciation for wealth, hard work,
and success.
So, they didn’t just go out and burn all
of Alhassan’s wealth.
In fact, they actually did a great job in
maintaining the business and expanding into
more sectors including rice and oats.
With that being said though, none of them
were that ambitious, and they didn’t do
much to take the business to the next level.
That is until Aliko Dangote.
Aliko Dangote was born in Kano on April 10,
1957.
Given that Alhassan had passed away 2 years
before that, Alhassan’s son or Aliko’s
grandfather Sanusi Dantata was running the
business.
Aliko’s father actually passed away early
on, so Aliko would primarily be raised by
his grandfather Sanusi.
This gave Aliko a unique view into the daily
operations of the business and made him really
interested in growing his own business.
Aliko would attend Al-Azhar university which
is widely known as being the most prestigious
university in the Islamic world.
Aliko earned a bachelors in business in 1977,
and he would return to Nigeria with a business
idea ready to go.
His plan was to follow his great grandfather’s
footsteps and expand to soft commodities.
Instead of selling the commodities to Europeans
though, Aliko wanted to import commodities
into Africa and sell them to local consumers.
His first two targets were rice from Thailand
and sugar from Brazil.
And to get his business started up, he borrowed
some money from his family.
Some reports suggest that he borrowed the
money from his uncle while others suggest
that the money was from his grandfather.
But either way, he got a $2500 loan from one
of his family members and he promised to pay
them back within three years.
Now, that’s no small loan of a million dollars,
but adjusting for inflation, it’s equivalent
to $11,200 today.
So not a small amount per se.
Given his family’s reputation, it wasn’t
too difficult for Aliko to secure some international
suppliers and start selling rice and sugar
locally.
According to Aliko, the business was a cash
cow, and he profited as much as $10,000 per
day.
That’s the same as $44,800 today.
Aliko paid back his family member within 3
months, and he was off to the races.
Over the next two decades, Aliko expanded
from just selling rice and sugar to also selling
pasta, salt and flour.
By expanding his reach in Africa and his line
of products, Aliko grew his personal fortune
to hundreds of millions of dollars.
But, he wouldn't reach the elusive billion
dollar mark till he embarked on his great
grandfather’s final vision.
Up until 1997, Aliko was simply a middleman
funneling commodities into Africa.
But in 1997, Aliko decided to venture into
production and stop being the middleman.
He already had a large customer base and plenty
of money though, so the transition wouldn’t
be too difficult and Aliko would quickly grow
to be one of the only billionaires in Nigeria.
At this point, the Nigerian government would
actually trust him enough to award him a cement
factory.
To this day, we don’t really know the details
behind why they awarded him the factory.
Maybe the factory was failing and they wanted
him to stage a recovery or maybe it was a
thank you gift for driving down sugar prices.
I’m not sure, but whatever the reason, Aliko
was awarded a cement factory and he would
leverage the factory to expand into cement
production as well.
According to Aliko, the key to his success
has been his tendency to reinvest the majority
of his profits back into business.
Apparently, most Afrcan businessmen like to
keep most of their money in cash for some
reason.
All of this reinvesting seems to have worked
out for Aliko as all of his businesses boast
extremely impressive stats today.
The Dangote sugar refinery, for instance,
is the third largest in the world producing
a whopping 800,000 tonnes of sugar annually.
Considering this, it’s not surprising that
Aliko Dangote has been Africa’s richest
person since 2012.
Since reaching the pinnacle of success in
the business world, Aliko has shifted to focusing
on advancing Nigeria as a whole.
In 2009, for instance, Aliko focused on providing
fast internet service to Nigerians by installing
14,000 kilometers of fibre optic.
His latest project is to reduce and potentially
even eliminate Nigeria’s dependence on oil
imports.
Currently, Nigeria imports $7 billion worth
of fuel every year despite the fact that Nigeria
is the biggest oil producer in Africa.
Aliko is investing $15 billion, which is more
than his net worth, into building one of the
world’s biggest oil refineries in Africa.
Hopefully, the oil refinery does come to fruition
and help Nigeria become more oil independent.
But, that’s what Aliko Dangote is working
on today and how he became the richest person
in Africa.
What do you guys think about the story of
Aliko and especially his great grandfather
Alhassan?
Comment that down below.
Also, drop a like if you would like to see
Africa catch up to western world.
And of course consider joining our discord
community to suggest future video ideas and
consider subscribing to see more questions
logically answered.